So yeah thank you uh for come to my talk
today so today I'm just going to be
talking about
um kind of a chemistry application and
generating approximate ground states of
molecules using Quantum machine learning
um yeah I just wanted to get started
then so just kind of a quick road map of
what I'm going to talk about in this
talk
um just intro to quantum chemistry not
going to spend too much time on it since
we've kind of discussed it already today
um our model that we talked about so
what we're going to do is we're trying
to use
um wave functions so like the ground
state of a molecule as Quantum data in a
Quantum machine learning problem so kind
of
um
and
essentially we want to see okay well how
well does this work for some very small
molecular systems in a very ideal case
um we're not necessarily going to be
looking it's there's some ideas that
could apply to nisk things but this
material wasn't really done with nisk in
mind from this outset so just keep that
in mind some things that we did find
were we were able to prove some
limitations on what you can learn in
this situation for these type of models
and then kind of want to open it to uh
there's there's a lot of different
directions this work could take and some
open questions regarding that so okay
great
so of course as we've kind of heard
already why do we want to simulate
chemistry well one is how to predict uh
reaction rates
um chemical reaction rates and typically
right this is in drug design catalysis
material synthesis this is a very
important property and primarily this is
investigated again through the ground
state problem sorry
there we go
um as as we've discussed right the
ground state problems this has had a lot
of work and classical Theory and also in
Quantum simulation as well
um but I kind of wanted to discuss why
do we actually care about the ground
state problem and some of the larger
contexts I think Nick discussed this a
little bit earlier
um talking about some of the specific
applications but
um yeah let's let's get into this
so okay as we know the quantum chemistry
model
um typically what we're doing is we
assume we have a classical nuclei which
are just point charges in space and then
the electrons are treated Quantum
mechanically with some Atomic orbitals
so I mean you can either do plane waves
in a box or typically uh there's they're
3D gaussian basis functions
okay so right the ground state
electronic structure problem is given
this hamiltonian of one and two body
interactions in the electronic structure
problem uh we want to find the lowest
eigenvalue right
um so specifically though
um things that are not as uh or it's not
not talked about as much as that right
for a lot of different problems when we
want to compute different
um or compute reaction rates is we
actually want the ground state at
different nuclear positions so we have a
family of hamiltonians that are actually
parameterized by R here
in r in this case is the vector of the
Cartesian coordinates of all the
different nuclear positions so if you
had two nuclei you'd have to have six
numbers representing where they are in
3D space
so
um it's not just one ground state we
need we need a family of ground states
to compare energies right we don't
necessarily care about just the enter
the ground state energy as is doesn't
really tell us anything unless we're
comparing it to another value
all right yeah so I touched on this a
little bit
um the the family of ground States we
need right kind of uh in this 2D map
um so this is like the degree of
rotation of of
of this axis here on this four atom
molecule this nitrate ion
um basically every point on this
Topography is a ground state calculation
right so we'd actually need in order to
compare the energy like let's say right
here at this Minima and the one of this
deeper Minima over here
a priori we don't even we don't know
um like what's the shortest path or the
paths with the smallest transition
energy here right so
um excuse me so one of the things to
think about right is that even if we did
have
um
uh fault tolerant computer or fall
tolerant quantum computer we'd have to
and we were able to run like Quantum
phase estimation and get correct ground
States easily we'd have to do it naively
we'd have to compute it at every one of
these points or at least with some
discretization so that that's a very
large overhead that we'd maybe
um there we don't have to do as naively
maybe this is something we can learn if
we just sample you know sparsely around
those
okay so yeah again
right this can be this is just a 2d
example but really this is a higher
dimensional object it's you know like
three Cartesian coordinates per atom
um so and of course as we've kind of
already discussed we do need these
energies to be highly accurate because
to compute reaction rates they're in an
exponential function so that's why you
require this thing called chemical
accuracy
Okay so
as I was just kind of explaining at the
end of the last slide
um right we need to sample the like we
need a ground state energy at each point
if we want to compute this reaction rate
and we need to know we don't even know
where the local Minima are and different
transition States so the things of that
sort so like this kind of whole
topography the thing we call the
potential energy surface is something
that's not known with high accuracy
beforehand
so again right like even if we were able
to compute it we'd have to compute a lot
of different points a lot of different
phase estimations with a lot of
different hamiltonians
so okay the idea is that I kind of
already alluded to this but instead of
using it to compute the ground state
over and over again on the potential
energy surface we want to utilize wave
functions like sparsely sampled on the
PES as Quantum data for a qml problem
all right so what do I mean by a
generative QQ qml model so sometimes uh
you might have seen this before this
this Quantum machine learning so-called
Punnett Square uh where you're looking
at the type of algorithm versus the type
of data you care about so in this case I
really think uh we're squarely in this
QQ regime so what we mean is the data
that we want to learn with is the actual
ground state wave function if we're able
to get that that's the data and learn to
predict the wave function or a
preparation of it at another state that
wasn't in the training set
and of course doing this with a Quantum
algorithm to simulate the physics so
we're squarely in this QQ regime
so all right this is kind of a high
level overview of what we're thinking so
you have some input molecule that's
parameterized by where the nuclear
positions are you have a number of basis
functions that represent it and number
of electrons
um what you normally do is compute uh
the handle the coefficients of the
hamiltonian with your favorite quantum
chemistry package
um you'd then feed this of course into a
compiler let's say for phase estimation
this would be all the gates needed to uh
do the e to the i h of R times T and
hopefully extract uh grounded
um uh ground state uh energy with some
initial overlap
um as as was mentioned a few times
before as well
um so yeah that's right the main routine
molecule you get you compute the
hamiltonian which is relative which is
classically efficient
then you choose some simulation and
rotate your initial guess State into a
final state
so since we have this family of
hamiltonians over R maybe what we can do
is if we fix
right a sequence of unitaries we can
maybe learn these thetas directly and
generalize over the r input over a few
pieces of quantum data which is the
ground state
right so something like a neural network
directly has the input is just
um
the nuclear coordinates and the
definition of the system we care about
and the outputs thetas to some fixed
circuit so that that's kind of the idea
we're going to run with here and I'll be
a little bit more specific in a second
and
um
as I alluded to so there's some big
assumptions here
um the first one's not so bad right so
the initial state is easy to prepare in
a lot of cases it's an assumption but we
expect the overlap of the initial states
to have some constant uh there's some
constant overlap with the true ground
state
um and one of the biggest assumptions
here right of course is that we're
saying oh we have access to a few ground
States for the training data that of
course is a big assumption because we
know we can't prepare necessarily
prepare these in general but the idea
here was more of a proof of concept to
see well if we can generalize really
well with only a few exact ground States
that's motivation to move this project
forward where we have
um imperfect uh preparations of the
ground state and see how much noise
affects that so that would be something
of future work but really we just want
to see how well does it work in the most
ideal case can we actually learn
Elsewhere on the potential extrapolate
elsewhere
okay so here's kind of a more
specific schematic of what we're doing
right so we have the definition of our
molecule which has nuclear coordinates
that's fed into a classical neural
network which outputs thetas for a fixed
uh unitary here it's this unitary of
course in is just called unn in general
but
um in many cases you want this to be
probably close to the problem physically
inspired by in our case it's singles and
doubles Givens rotations on the
um on the molecular space here
um
so
we know that preparing the mean field
state is simple so the initial State
here right we have a register that holds
it for the ice nuclear configuration
um and of course this uh we also prepare
this again on another register
um this would be the the ground state
prep right this is the large assumption
that we're able to actually prepare this
true synod.ori
but the idea here is that well if we
choose a cost function
and we can evaluate the gradients
efficiently given this setup here then
essentially all we have to do is go back
and update the classical neural network
to Output New thetas and iterate there
until we get learning a general function
of PSI naught tilde over the select R's
that we chose
so at the end what we get is that well
if we want a new molecule that was in
the data set we just input the new
coordinates
right we cheaply generate a bunch of
thetas for this and we're able to rotate
the mean field State into an approximate
ground state so this is the key point
right here
if there's any questions at this point
that's probably a good place
cool so yeah again this is the
the main concept here is that we're
saving if we're able to actually learn
this representation with this setup here
the classical neural network the quantum
circuit then we wouldn't have to run our
simulation algorithm over and over again
we can just generate the new thetas
so what do we actually do we just used a
very simple cross function this is just
average Fidelity so in this case this is
like the approximate
SCI tilde with uh using the neural
network parameters to uh so this is the
approximate side this is the true side
again it's just an average over the N
different samples we took of those
ground States we also found that the
gradient of evaluation is efficient and
we looked at either doing it term by
term for each of those gamma parameters
in the classical neural network by using
the hadamard test or coherently as
possible as well of course that's more
in The Fault tolerant regime
so yeah this is this is very simple cost
function
that can evaluate the gradient
efficiently
um this is not as important but this is
just the specific informal theorem for
the hadamard test method so just has to
do with how many samples we have
um and the max value of the gradient of
the classical neural network
um so yeah
all right great
so the key points again
are that right we can we want to learn
the wave function itself or at least
some approximate representation of it so
that we can probe the system later with
any observable we want not necessarily
just the energy
um and of course also found of course
that there's a an efficient gradient
evaluation that we can do that's
theoretically tractable in a sense
okay
so how well does this work so
essentially what we did
um was test this on a few examples of
toys toy model systems in chemistry
um and yeah so we use the Jordan finger
mapping so one qubit is one spin orbital
that's the Assumption you're making
through this and use you know some very
minimal bases for these these molecules
um and fix some onsats dependent on
um given rotations that looks like that
look like this uh the singles and
doubles rotations
um anyways
so the interesting thing here all right
so first is this H4 rectangular stretch
so H4 is kind of this toy strongly
correlated model that shows up in
chemistry so strongly correlated meaning
that there's a bunch of different
electronic configurations that are close
together that are needed to represent
the ground state
um and it's not just dominated by one
single configuration so typically it's a
hard problem uh to accurately get so
okay so the first thing we did on the
left here is the energy
so this is the energy of the system
um red is the actual model that we found
or that that we developed
um the teal is the true ground state
energy at all of these points along here
and that this is just again
stretching these atoms like this in a
rectangular fashion
blue is the mean field state if you're
just to use the classically efficient
and meat like archery Fox state to
compute the energy see it's squarely
above
um
the true grounds today for most of this
um but I I guess the yeah
um the interesting thing right is that
each one of these dots
right so we've used only five uh ground
States at each of these R values so one
here one here and then the three others
over here so that's all we use for
training this classical neural network
um we can see that already what's kind
of surprising just by kind of sampling
you know at the equilibrium geometry
then a few more closer to dissociation
that we're getting it uh pretty good
extrapolations past the data set that we
wouldn't
um expect so what that's telling us is
that there's a lot of Rich information
in the actual wave function as a Quantum
data object right
and so on the right hand side here this
isn't energy anymore this is Fidelity so
this is the model the teal in this case
sorry the color is a little bit
confusing but the teal in this case is
the ground state wave function
overlapped with the model wave function
so you see we have something that's
fairly stays fairly High to Fidelity
over this whole
um
uh Bond stretching coordinate and then
the blue one is the mean field state
with the true ground state and of course
it starts to drop off as you pull the
bond apart
okay so that's
pretty interesting but we're not really
getting the correct energy and
extrapolating out to pulling the
molecule totally apart right in the
dissociation limit
but just by one idea of course is just
well maybe we don't have enough of this
uh information from the dissociated part
so let's just kind of shift the data
points over
so we do that and get
um
I have no idea why this is 90 degrees or
I've rotated so sorry must be the uh
that's that's weird so apologies uh but
okay let's look at the left so on the
left right we just shifted the um
uh we just shifted some of the points
over or added actually what we did is
just add one more point over here into
our model and we get extremely good
agreement with some deviation right here
at the
um difficult kind of like the Midway
molecular dissociation but the
interesting thing of course is that
right we can extrapolate that there's
some dissociation limit and that you
know we get this uh repulsion curve as
the atoms get too close together and
that's all just from a few of the wave
functions sampled at each of these
points and then trading a classical
neural network to rotate those thetas
the right way so at each of these new
points in the model I'm sorry this one
right at each one of these new points
all we're doing is saying I want the
correct unitary to rotate the mean field
State at you know six bore and we can
just generate that right
so that that part is surprising that
with such few points it was able to do
this
okay so of course that's just a 1D case
and while this is
um a really simple system it was just to
give you an idea of in two Dimensions we
get uh similar quality results so
um just kind of looking at the right
hand graph here this is again just six
points
um where angle is the y-axis here this
Theta H and distance uh symmetric
distance is this Delta H here and we
only do six and I mean most of this map
is almost uh Fidelity of one for the
other states that we sampled
or sorry for the uh
the data that's generated that wasn't in
the training set
um with some uh loss of fidelity over
here but of course if we just add you
know a few more points we get pretty
high fidelity overall so again
it's kind of the same story though that
this system is pretty small so uh the H4
ones may be more representative
but still we see that at least for the
one and two D toy model cases that we
looked at we really got a lot of
information from just a few ground
States that's kind of the main takeaway
so I'll shift gears like a little bit
um we looked at we have some theoretical
results in this work about the
limitations on learning
um and I'll go into one example of that
um so kind of the idea was that
naturally if you sample from one region
of a potential energy surface can we
bound how much we can learn
um somewhere else farther away that's
the idea
so
um one way we cut try to investigate
this is to look at adiabatic grow
research problem
so
um there's this paper from 2002 from
Roland and surf that Maps the
unstructured search problem onto an
adiabatic time Evolution problem so
essentially what you get is this
hamiltonian that's parameterized by S
where s is the reduced time
um this
unfortunately got messed up by the
upload so sorry but this is a h0 is a
projector onto the superposition of all
bitstrings
so 1 minus that projector and hm is the
projector onto the selected uh M state
that you're searching for so yeah
apologies that this is you can't really
read this but yeah this should be one
minus KET M bra M and then one minus cat
PSI naught uh bra PSI naught
okay so anyway you have this uh
interpolated hamiltonian that goes from
you're starting in the state here right
the superposition of all bit strings and
then slowly
um uh time evolving over to the state M
and so what they found
um is that they found an optimal
Evolution time which is square root and
N right reproducing that quadratic speed
up that you see
so that this is this is optimal but the
idea here is that well maybe we can use
some of this tool
uh some of this tools I developed right
to what if we only evolve to points here
and say use these as samples before this
s star coordinate and try to see what
are the limits on us learning M from
just uh points on this left hand side
um
so yeah with that
um just like a summary of the theorem
because it's it's pretty long but
um we've first find uh correspondence
between the fermiona hamiltonian and the
Grover hamiltonian
um we map the reduced time parameter
this s uh to some arbitrary parameter
like the um coordinate right like the
bond coordinate
and oh sorry yeah uh but anyway so what
we can do is limit the sample region
like I said before s star and this
threshold ensures that there's
um basically we prove by contradiction
that there's no algorithm that can learn
M with a number of wave function data
samples that requires less than o root n
queries to the hamiltonian
so this is kind of a worst case scenario
in chemistry right like this Gap is a
function of right this has exponentially
small overlap with increasing number of
n bit strings
um but it has to follow this lower bound
so the intuition you should get from
this of course is that if we have
um like a ground state and excited state
potential energy surface that have a
really small Gap naturally it's going to
be harder to learn through the Gap if
it's confined to this one dimension now
in general right
you could imagine this expanded into two
dimensions and if you take a path that
kind of goes around the edge with a
larger Gap in that so it looks like two
parabolas right it's like one curving
down one like this if you take a path
that's around it you won't be
um restricted just by that minimum Gap
in that 2D space so really this is kind
of like a worst case scenario of what
you can learn here
so the takeaway of course is that
naturally there's no Universal
exponential speed up allowed to just
learn across the potential energy
surface anywhere
um
and algorithms that we can learn from
the or algorithms that can learn that
unknown State somewhere else in the
potential energy surface have to satisfy
these lower bounds on query complexity
for the unstructured search Problem
um and yeah so sampling States
um
on you know like uh more spark like if
we sample farther away at larger R's
naturally gives us a better
generalization
um of uh the whole surface kind of as
expected
so some some open questions
future directions so looking back at
um kind of the the setup of this model
of course what we want to look at is how
do errors in the ground state prep right
if we just have some constant overlap
how does that affect the actual output
quality for the approximate ground
States
is there any viability here for State
prep routines and nisk I don't know
um
what type of like we just used a really
simple feed forward classical neural
network there's lots of different
architectures of course like is there
any ideal Choice there
is there a better way to generate the
quantum neural network part that doesn't
require
um us kind of selecting these Givens
rotations somewhat arbitrarily
um and what's the interplay between
these two right this is quite unexplored
um
also would you know instead of just
using the mean field State and rotating
that to our suppose or hopefully the
ground state what a higher quality
classical input with higher overlap
always be preferable or is that just
extra overhead that we don't need and of
course
we only really looked at one dimension
or sorry one and two Dimensions but in
general R for large molecules is going
to be some very high dimensional objects
so does this still perform as R scales
up
um
and of course too we use a very simple
cost Fidelity cost function on average
and
um that's the only one that we explored
so far so there's other choices that can
be done there as well
all right
so some conclusions
um
the general like architecture and cost
function we think is promising but again
this is kind of a proof of concept and
there's a lot of stuff we need to still
learn about this
um
again as a
reiterated on the last Slide the high
dimensional PES could still be a problem
and we don't know
but um one of the big takeaways I think
is that at least just a few points of
these Quantum data as the ground state
wave function seems to be quite
information Rich for
extrapolating to other parts of the
potential energy surface and I think
that that was
um somewhat surprising how well it did
but of course for practical applications
we're going to have to see how noise
affects this or how imperfect uh Quantum
data actually you know at what point
does it ruin the model
um yeah with that just want to
acknowledge my co-authors and then of
course Brigida Whaley numesh to uh
hosting me as postdoc here at the
Simon's Institute and thank you all for
your attention
[Applause]
yep
bottom
one year or Community outfitting
something that's intractable like RPMs
and yeah that's
I actually thought yeah I mean like in
general this doesn't have to be on a qpu
right like I mean you could do exactly
what you're saying and I haven't I've
thought about it but I haven't like
implemented anything in terms of
classical methods though I think it
would be just for classical ml for
chemistry would be a nice Target like a
nice way to think about this problem
yep
um let's see let me go back here
it's on the
okay so yeah so this the the Fidelity
cost function here so you're saying what
would be the time
yes
um
you made the experiment the runs
HD works better collapse oh yeah so some
of the Assumption we're making here
right is that we have some we're lower
bounded by some constant Factor overlap
even as the size increases because we
can generate the mean field state with
decent overlap each time even as n grows
that that can Decay exponentially within
even though all the expectations
so I think that there's I think this
maybe this is brought up in Lynn's talk
yesterday is that there's some debate
about whether or not uh the overlap is
going to be always some constant Factor
but in this work we're making that
assumption because I mean in practice
even for like the the H4 model function
like the overlap for a lot of these
cases was like 50 or greater
and as that happens to be like in in
doing like classical quantum chemistry
the mean field state is still pretty
high overlap even for very large systems
um so there's an assumption we're making
what you're catching which is that we're
assuming there's some constant overlap
even regardless of the size of the
system we care about but maybe that's
not always the case and that's kind of a
debated Point currently but it's just an
assumption for our problem
um
with the gamma parameter yeah
yeah
uh sorry this n is number of samples so
number of ground States
so the you mean like the choice of this
unitary so for this case
um what we did was used actually I have
an extra slide on that one
so we did something that was like
adaptive eqe inspired so for each of
these we initialized the mean field
applied a set of double excitations
basically computed gradients for that
operator to some threshold then did the
singles and so then that was just a an
onsets for what uh we thought the unn
should be but this is this is what we
did
yep
yeah so then there's there's doubt like
product of doubles then singles to get
those two different rotations on the
single particle excitations and double
particle excitations
yep
yes
yeah so I think yeah that was one of my
questions too I mean I think it's a good
question it's would a higher quality
classical input uh like if I just had a
better better than mean field but still
something classically efficient
um that obviously gives me a higher
overlap but is that always preferable in
practice I don't know I mean it depend
on the cost of each one of these things
individually but I think of course it
would help in the training
[Applause]